have you ever had a guest that you were
incredibly excited to have hence you
invited them but then once you don't
have to give names but then once they
came here they completely tanked and
your your physician
without giving names there might be a
certain candidate yeah for president
that has been here so when i used to
when i used to do uh
i mean i mean listen joe jorgensen i
will say the name because now it's like
people talk about it not because in a
bad way
but i wanted like i brought joe
jorgensen because i wanted to go deeper
in libertarian policies you know who
george
yeah yeah and she didn't want to do that
and when basic questions were ants asked
i didn't you know
push her too hard i asked her basic
questions who's the toughest debate
you've ever had
you know because a lot of times
people in your world they just talk a
lot and there's no pushback there's no
debate from from the world like the
stanford people that you're talking to
you're going to get pushed back because
if you're in the circle people going to
push back oh you're wrong you're this
you're that and you'll banter with them
whether it's on twitter there's a part
of me that i think actually likes that
to have that banter i don't think she
has
been punched it's like the person that's
read all the books on boxing and has
watched all the fights but hasn't been
in too many well that's the concept of
anti-fragility right you need to be
exposed to stressors for your system
he's a beast by the way yeah he's a
beast have you done stuff with him or no
no anti-friday
yeah he's somebody that i uh
i listen i had every single one of my
executives in the company read skin in
the game everybody yeah if folks if
you're having red skin in a game even if
it's not a newer book it's like five six
years old whatever eight years old i
highly recommend reading uh that book
you know one of the things that i can i
can put on my cv with pride it's sick
book is for the author oh you've never
read
let me tell you let me tell you a story
about nasim nasim basically hates 99 of
humanity right to him everybody is a
fraud everybody's a charlatan now i'm
lucky enough to have never made it into
that camp i've always been in in the you
know psychologists are full of [ __ ] this
is naseem speaking except god said
all these academics are full of [ __ ]
except you know god sat and so i've
always said as long as i've gotten a
seam on my side i think i'm doing the
right thing because this guy truly is a
i mean he's a honey badger maybe on
steroids in the sense that
he tends to go after people sometimes in
in a rough way where they they don't
necessarily deserve it i mean i don't
know if you agree with that he he's a
fantastic guy he's a lovely guy he's a
very good friend we spoke on the phone
he's in lebanon now a couple of weeks
ago but he's lebanese as well he's also
that this guy is
and he i mean he does not suffer fools
godly you know i mean he's got you he he
goes after you by the way you're a
self-identified honey badger trivia
question for the both of you yeah what
nfl pro bowler
heisman candidate
is nicknamed the honey badger oh no
famous name it's like the the nickname
give me position what position
plays defense defensive back yeah i like
the offensive i figured you would know
this this is like this guy's nickname
he's like a safety that's true for that
truth because my son actually i don't
remember his name but he said daddy look
they're using your terms yeah exactly
what did he play for who did he play for
plays for kansas uh played for kansas
city for a long time
how do you say it tyrone uh
is he a recent guy number three yeah
he's a famous guy 32. he almost won the
heisman he might have even won the
heisman i don't know
very famous who's this tyrone matthew
yeah number 32. okay pro bowl check
check is
brady talks so much trash to the they
went back and forth but this guy didn't
back down brady didn't back down uh and
by the way going back to joe jorgensen i
walked away
i walked away thinking to myself
are they prepping candidates
like are they doing the behind the
closed doors conversations like what is
the process for somebody to be the cat
in canada and then we had dave smith
here and i said how does
the libertarian party do you know how
the libertarian party chooses their vps
no the candidate doesn't the party does
mm-hmm so did you know this or no so
jones was explaining that not spike john
cohen spike jones you went to a
completely different this guy threw you
off by the way so no but but libertarian
party you don't pick your vp
you you run
and you run to become the vp so you run
not only to become the president the
nominee but you also run to become the
vp which means there is no synergy
between the two which i think that
system is broken because they got to get
along they got to be on the same page
very weird there's a there's certain
changes that parties got to make there
are arguments a lot of them i fully
agree with but uh joe jorgensen threw me
off but yeah i've had had a few other
interviews that i did where
i was like this is going to be not that
good but it ended up being great those
are the ones that are very why do you
ask that question by the way oh just
because i'm you know i'm someone who
just lives life to its fullest and so
i'm always when i wake up and i have a
guest coming i'm always kind of gleeful
i'm excited i'm ready who was yours have
you had one or uh of the the one that
impressed me or the ones that operate
uh
negative yes i had a political scientist
from i think boston university that was
a total
as you know
inviting someone simply because they
have good credentials won't necessarily
lead to a good conversation they have to
also have the personality so if you
bring someone and you're pulling teeth
because they answer you very dry and
especially if you're doing it remotely
where you know it's yeah you need i need
to get a bit of fire out of you man and
if i can't get that it's gonna die very
quickly and for us to maintain it for an
hour so i would say probably that guy
just because of his personality who was
better than expected meaning you're like
i'm excited for this but whoa bam that
turned out to be incredible well the
most powerful one was a gentleman who
spent 29 years in prison for a murder
that he didn't commit
and i actually have him in the in the
last chapter of my next book that i'm
working on now recipe for the good life
i i use them as an example for how to
live without anger in your heart because
as we were chatting i said to him
you know you you must be the new age
buddha
because if i were in your position
you're a much better man than i am
because if i were in your position i'd
want to be burning down the world right
because i would be so angry and venomous
and yet the guy was so
gracious he had such uh you know such
such gratitude at life and actually he
said something very powerful to me which
i i discussed in the book his his sister
i think suffers from cerebral palsy and
she's bedridden her whole life and so he
i said well how did you do it to stay so
grounded he said well look i see what my
sister's going through and yet she has a
smile on her face so i had no reason to
be filled with hate in my heart so a guy
just spent almost three decades in
prison and is acting with such
incredible grace and so i said i need to
have so far so i would probably say of
all the great guests i've had that guy's
life lesson is right up there david
mccallum by the way that's his name
when i hear stories like that it's it's
heartbreaking and then how they can be
positive about it all
but we did have a guest recently i won't
say the name where he was
what i would say non-committal what do
you think yeah you could go either way
with it mm-hmm older gentlemen yeah i'm
talking about it we we took them out to
dinner yeah and during dinner i remember
the day do you remember the dinner yeah
yeah so
you know you like food not really
i was so excited for him too i was like
i've been watching was he your guess he
was you you nominated i've been
following that guy for ever i always by
the way he he's he he's a qualified
genius like he's got well that's the
problem right yeah but i don't like
friends sitters i always say that the
ones who equivocate are never the ones
who are interesting to hang out with you
want people who i mean you want that if
they're opinionated they can back it up
but the ones who are always equivocating
on the fence they're very would you say
that this gentleman that we have in mind
was a fence sitter
yeah but but you know who i liked a lot
who called me a freaking [ __ ] on the
interview at the end do you know who
thomas jefferson's uh yeah is uh what's
the guy's name it's uh
uh he's got one of those lucian truscott
yes you ever seen this one no yeah i had
lucian truscott on and i asked him a
question i said so you want thomas
jefferson's statue to be replaced by
harriet tubman and you want it to be
removed to a different place i never
said remove i said but you wanted to go
to a different location or yes
i said what's your problem with thomas
jefferson he's it's his great great
great great grandfather
and i said so why why do you have such a
big problem with thomas jefferson he
just kept saying stuff saying stuff same
stuff find a clip real quick because
it's very entertaining it's right off
the bat you'll see it
anyways eventually i said um
eventually i said so who's your favorite
president he didn't want to answer it
i said tell me who's your favorite
president
and he said
barack obama click on it he said barack
obama i said and then go to all the way
to the end just take it all the way to
the end all the way to the end all the
way to the end all the way a little bit
back a little bit back a little bit back
with you yeah
are one of my favorite interviews of all
time
yeah i wish you nothing but the best
okay
all good take care of yourself
goodbye bye bye
it doesn't seem happy listen go back go
back go back go back oh [ __ ]
i wish you nothing but the best
okay
all good take care of yourself
goodbye bye bye
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is all the notes i prefer
and i gotta tell you it's one of my top
10 favorite interviews of all time
do you know why though you know why
though because he actually has a
position yeah and he was pushing so hard
and he was he was not like he was
hardcore on his position
and uh we had banter and uh it was it
was exciting so why
why were you an
[ __ ] because you were challenging him
on his position because because the only
people he interviews with is people that
agree with him agree with them and i was
surprised that he said yes because i
asked for him he said yes i said great
see this is the challenge when sometimes
a guy he's just a youtuber and they're
like oh [ __ ] i'm sitting down with you
yeah what's happening with this guy
oh i wasn't ready for this we should
have done a little research i had no
idea i thought this was just that's all
good i'm kind of glad you didn't do any
research thank you for not doing
research because it allows us to have a
little more fun here's another question
for you do you think that given your
middle eastern background that you
you know uh take your foot off the the
pedal and are nicer to guess precisely
because of the hospitality culture
and before you answer i do that because
on on twitter when i engage people i can
be quite irratible right if you start
pissing me off i'm gonna come after you
and your ancestors and your future
descendants right i can be combative
right but if you come on my show all
that goes away because you're now a
guest that's mine
and it's just simply gauche for me too
so people will sometimes get upset at me
and say why didn't you destroy this guy
i said well but he was a guest i can't i
there's a code of conduct once you agree
to be in my home
and so i'm wondering if you have the
same kind of uh etiquette yes but but if
you're if you if it gets okay so for me
many times i've done interviews and i've
looked like a fool because i didn't know
the information and the other person's
but i'm learning yeah yeah so i'm not
doing this because i'm trying to teach
the world about what i know that my
expertise is business
i'm doing this because i'm going through
the process of learning and recreating
myself and have certain philosophies and
beliefs and i wanted to get stronger and
the only way that happens is by people
saying you're wrong we're going to tell
me why
never thought about that before how
about this
and then we go into that mode where it
gets heated and there's a lot of banter
then
comes out good ideas so i enjoy those
and i'm respectful but i have no problem
pushing the envelope i mean you have to
realize i've sat with
sammy to bulgarvano i mean this this
guy's not like a you know you're upset
with uh michael francis yes i've sat
with the mobsters i've sat with phil
leonetti the former underboss of the
philadelphia crime family i've sat with
you know
people that have done 30 years jail time
i i want to know like what the motive is
with certain things so uh very uh
respect no matter who the individual is
this doesn't mean you support what life
this person lived but it's purely
respect to want to learn and it's worked
out well so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here